bonsoir à tous bienvenue voici les
titres de votre journal 256000 sens et
le nombre de destructions d'emplois en
2009 à l'exception de l'intérim tous les
secteurs sont touchés
le nombre d'entreprises a reculé lui
aussi les chiffres sont définitifs ce
sont les plus mauvais depuis
l'après-guerre la police visé par les
tirs hier soir à villiers-le-bel et dans
la nuit de mardi à mercredi à auxerre
des incidents qui n'ont pas fait de
blessé et à grenoble aujourd'hui brice
hortefeux a réitéré son discours
sécuritaire encore un contrecoup de la
crise les assureurs vont augmenter les
primes l'année prochaine assuré votre
voiture se fera jusqu'à 5% de plus un
témoin un model naomi campbell a raconté
aujourd'hui à la cour pénale
internationale commente charles taylor
lui a offert des diamants tachées du
sang des guerres civiles en afrique
l'ancien dictateur du liberia jugé pour
crimes contre l'humanité
changement de cap changement de ton
changement de style et surtout l'équipe
laurent blanc a dévoilé la composition
de celle qui affrontera la norvège
mercredi prochain
aucun des 23 joueurs du mondial ne sera
sur la feuille de match
enfin c'est le film d'action de l'été
avec des expendables sylvester stallone
signe son grand retour devant et
derrière la caméra et réunit une
distribution de rêve
il a présenté il ya une heure son film
en avant première à rosny sous bois
il est l'invité de ce journal bonsoir
sylvester stallone à tout à l'heure
mais d'abord c'est un recul de 1 et demi
pourcent dit comme ça cela paraît peu et
pourtant c'est la baisse de l'emploi la
plus importante enregistrée depuis
l'après-guerre 256 1100 postes ont été
détruits en 2009 les chiffres définitifs
ont été publiés aujourd'hui emplois
féminins secteur tertiaire personne n'a
été épargné par la crise les
explications de julien du père est un
record de précarité en 2009 le nombre
d'emplois détruits a atteint le même
niveau qu'à cette période
l'après guerre et son économie at-elle
de l'année dernière l'emploi a baissé de
1,5 pour cent ce sont plus de 250 6000
postes en moins 2009 l'année où les
effets de la crise financière touche
l'économie réelle
l'industrie perd 168 1200 postes moins
5,2 pour cent la construction - 43 mille
huit cents emplois première baisse dans
le secteur depuis onze ans le tertiaire
est très touchée aussi 44 1200 postes en
moins surtout dans le commerce pour la
première fois depuis 1993 l'emploi des
femmes repart à la baisse - 51 1400
postes pour les hommes c'est pire - 204
mille sept cent des salariés au chômage
cela veut dire des établissements qui
ferment en 2009 le nombre d'entreprises
diminuent aussi l'économie française
n'avait pas vécu tel phénomène depuis 33
ans
l'année 2010 elle semble suivre la même
tendance
les chiffres du chômage ne se sont
toujours pas stabilisée l'industrie qui
emploie 19 % des salariés français
continuent de payer le prix fort de la
crise l'équipementier automobile new
fabris symbolise à lui seul les déboires
de centaines d'employés du secteur
romain beauty sébastien laffargue en
plein coeur de l'été
c'est un cri d'alarmé presque passée
inaperçue où sont les emplois un an
après affiche la banderole devant la
mairie de leur ville
il interpelle les pouvoirs publics avec
la peur d'être oublié juillet 2009
les salariés de new fabris font un coup
déclarent ils menacent de faire sauter
leur usine à coups de bonbonnes de gaz
pour protester contre leur licenciement
un an plus tard la plupart des new
fabris cherche toujours un emploi comme
alain caillau 54 ans opérateur technique
toute sa vie chez new fabris
dès 12 mois passé il retient les heures
à éplucher les annonces les formations
aux entretiens
aucune embauche mais des propositions
pour le moins surprenante
au départ on m'a proposé de postes un
poste de
manager et là on m'a demandé d'avoir le
si j'avais le bafa jeudi que bon bien
sûr en ayant travaillé chez fabrice 35
ans bon bah je n'avais pas ce diplôme en
question quoi et après on va proposer
justement un autre poste d'archéologue
et ce n'est pas vraiment un cas isolé
car ils ne sont que 30 chez les new
fabris sur les 366 avoir retrouvé un
emploi stable chez des continental pas
mieux seulement 100 sur 1200 chez 3m 72
sur 107 tandis que chez les molex les
trois quarts sont toujours au chômage
un an après la vague de plans sociaux
l'industrie peine à reclasser ces
chômeurs alors ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à ne pas compter sur les
cellules de reclassement
c'est ce qu'a fait christian paupineau
48 ans lui aussi ancien opérateur
technique
depuis six mois il travaille en intérim
comme cariste une affaire de dignité
avant tout c'est quand même se dire que
qu'on est utile à quelque chose que de
rester chez soi se morfondent à rien
faire et tout ça peut pas durer c'est
s'aider granon déjà pour la personne
parce que dignement
avec le coup qu'on a suivi c'est pas
évident à encaisser tout ça donc non
c'est pour ça que faut rebondir le plus
vite possible
rebondir mais comment aujourd'hui des
services de retour à l'emploi doivent
faire face à un afflux de salariés
souvent hyper spécialisés est en fin de
carrière
alors que l'industrie est sinistrée les
policiers visés par des tirs d'armes à
feu hier soir à villiers-le-bel dans le
val-d'oise la patrouille a répliqué par
des tirs de flashball il n'y a pas eu de
blessés on a appris également qu'une
voiture de police avait été visée dans
la nuit de mardi à mercredi à auxerre
par un tir d'armé de projectiles un peu
plus tôt dans la journée un jeune homme
avait échappé à un contrôle
il a finalement été interpellé lionel
feierstein alexis jacquet c'est une
voiture siglée du commissariat d'auxerre
qui a été visé ce syndicaliste de la
police en est persuadé le tireur a
utilisé une arme à feu de petit calibre
de 10,22 ça il semble sauf lui
ressembler
toute façon c'est pas du corps en
suspens et pas du 4 5 1 c'est pas du
petit plomb - avec du grenat une maman 9
mm ça fait quand même ça fait quand même
un bel impact
un impact qui heureusement n'a pas fait
de blessés lundi soir dans le quartier
sainte-geneviève la seule cité sensible
de la ville des policiers ont été prises
à partie par une dizaine de personnes
certaines étaient cagoulés d'autres
armés de bâtons et de pierres une
réaction à l'arrestation plus tôt dans
la journée d'un automobiliste originaire
de la cité
le garçon était recherché après avoir
commis plusieurs infractions au code de
la route et c'est lors de ces incidents
de la nuit que des coups de feu aurait
éclaté
vous riez c'est un petit peu à tout
climat ambiant lie à grenoble
aujourd'hui à auxerre 1-1 des risques un
des risques c'est que il ya une forme de
mimétisme a passé un cap supérieur on
n'est plus dans le feu de poubelle ou
dans le jet de canette ou des choses
comme ça là on a sorti les armes et on
veut en découdre vraiment physiquement
depuis 24 heures le quartier
sainte-geneviève semble avoir retrouvé
son calme
il faut dire qu'en ce moment même une
quarantaine de crs est sur place les
effectifs qui devrait être encore
renforcés pour cette nuit
enfin à grenoble brice hortefeux a
clairement affiché son objectif faire de
la ville un symbole de la lutte contre
la délinquance le ministre de
l'intérieur a rendu visite aux policiers
et installer le groupement
d'intervention régional gir de l'isère
le tout assorti d'un discours
sécuritaire offensif sur place virginie
fille chez philips il est en garde à vue
depuis hier matin les trois derniers
jeunes gens encore retenus ont été
libérés à midi un quatrième garçon
relâché hier soir avait été interpellé
avec eux lors d'une opération de police
d'envergure
les enquêteurs souhaitaient les entendre
dans le cadre de l'enquêté sur le
braquage du casino d'uriage âgés de 15 à
23 ans ils ont été mis hors de cause
mais le ministre de l'intérieur venu
installer le tout nouveau groupement
d'intervention régional s'est toutefois
montré satisfait du résultat de leurs
auditions
l'objectif de ces interpellations
s'étaient de corroborer
le confirmer et de cerner et mieux
connaître l'identité du complice et
c'est un succès un succès pour brice
hortefeux un fiasco selon les avocats
des quatre hommes qui y voient davantage
un coup médiatique construit sur une
rumeur de quartier manoeuvre dénoncée
notamment par l'avocat du plus jeune des
gardés à vue
il fallait l'impressionner pour qu'ils
parlent mais qu'il dise quoi qui
confirme une rumeur on nous dit qu'on a
des éléments de police technique et
scientifique qui permettrait
d'identifier complice est bas alors
qu'on les exploite pourquoi est ce qu'on
a besoin d'aller arrêter un gamin de 15
ans pour confirmer une rumeur c'est pas
de la police c'est pas de l'enquète
c'est pas sérieux
les quatre hommes avaient été
interpellés pour leurs liens supposés
plus ou moins étroits avec karim
boudouda le braqueur qui a été tué à
l'issue de l'attaqué du casino d'uriage
les policiers espéraient même que son
complice serait peut-être parmi eux
complices qui à l'heure actuelle est
toujours en fuite
pour se refaire après une année
catastrophique les assureurs ont trouvé
la solution augmenter les primes l'année
prochaine assuré votre voiture vous
coûtera jusqu'à 5% de plus le montant
variera d'un assureur à l'autre et d'un
assuré à l'autre les explications d'yves
junca et johann nertomb même si vous
bénéficiez d'un bonus vous n'y couperez
pas les tarifs des assurances auto
devrait augmenter prochainement en 2011
jusqu'à + 5 % et d'ici 2013 + 9 %
une perspective confirmée aujourd'hui
par l'assureur mutualiste groupama et
qui ne surprend pas les comparateurs de
prix spécialisé depuis début 2010 déjà
la hausse est importante
théoriquement les assureurs quand ils
augmentent les prix ils augmentent sur
les périodes longues régulièrement et
sur plusieurs années en cause les
tempêtes de 2009 qui ont occasionné de
nombreux dégâts sur les véhicules
il ya aussi la hausse les accidents
matériels + 2 % et l'inflation du coût
des réparations + 4 % avec les tempêtes
et des inondations de cette année la
tendance ne devrait pas s'inverser
une mauvaise nouvelle pour les ménages
c'est d'autant plus une mauvaise
nouvelle que de manière générale les
assurances augmentent que soit
l'assurance habitation qui est elle
aussi sur 2010 hautement de 3 4% en
moyenne
les complémentaires santé qui elle
augmente encore plus
puisqu'on est sur du 4 à 6% pour
l'instant les chiffres ne sont pas
encore arrêtés mais la plupart des
compagnies d'assurances devraient
annoncer la hausse dès le mois de
septembre
un témoin modèles devant le tribunal
pénal international de la haye naomi
campbell a dû expliquer dans quelles
conditions
charles taylor lui a remis des diamants
des pierres précieuses tachées du sang
des guerres civiles en afrique
l'ancien dictateur du liberia doit
répondre de crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité renaud bernard avec
notre bureau à londres
naomi campbell voulait de la discrétion
vitres teintées pour éviter flash et
caméras mais c'est raté
le tribunal pénal international film
l'audience est celle que l'on surnommé
la panthère noire sur les podiums doit
se plier à la règle l'ex mannequin
témoigne sous serment contre charles
taylor l'ancien président du libéria
poursuivi pour crimes de guerre ils se
sont rencontrés lors d'un dîner chez
nelson mandela en voici la photo
ce soir là naomi campbell reçoit un
étonnant cadeau du chef de guerre au
milieu de la nuit il n'a frappé à la
porte j'ai ouvert et on m'a donné une
bourse il y avait quelques pièces elle
s'était très petit et très sale naomi
campbell joue les ingénues elle sait
pourtant que ces petites pierres sales
sont des diamants de sang ils ont semé
la terreur partout en afrique
tout a commencé ici freetown capitale de
la sierra leone dix ans de guerre civile
près de deux cent mille morts des
milliers de mutilés et autant
d'adolescents enrôlés de force comme
enfants soldats
pour financer leur guerre les rebelles
ont vendu des milliers de diamants et
ils ont été imités sur tout le continent
comme ici en afrique centrale
angola côte d'ivoire république
démocratique du congo congo brazzaville
liberia sierra leone à chaque fois le
même scénario
exemple avec la guerre civile en sierra
leone à l'époque les rebelles envoyés
des diamants à leurs alliés au liberia
de là les pierres partait vers les
grandes places diamantaire du monde pour
y être vendu avec cet argent
le liberia a acheté des armes pour les
livrer en retour aux rebelles sierra
léonais
on en est même fait un film avec
leonardo dicaprio
un film de cette ampleur avec un tel
budget et qui en plus véhicule un
message et politique
comment aurais-je pu ne pas sauter sur
l'occasion message politique car
officiellement depuis 2003 les diamants
de sang sont interdits un accord
international impose que chaque pierre
soit accompagnée d'un certificat une
preuve de sa virginité c'est le
processus de kimberley
selon les diamantaires il a assaini le
marché mondial 4% des diamants d'origine
douteuse en 99 1% seulement aujourd'hui
mais pour cette enquêtrice spécialisé
sur le trafic de diamants
le tableau n'est pas si rose par exemple
interdit par lots à gagner et pour ses
diamants sans certificat on trouve
toujours des acheteurs exemple à new
york
ce journaliste d'envoyé spécial va nous
le prouver en caméra cachée avec lui un
diamant de 50 mille dollars qu'il va
proposer dans cette boutique hôtel
vienne l'a fait quel pays congo
je n'ai pas de certificat et ont dit
qu'ils en font pour vendre ses pierres
ah oui le certificat kimberley bon tu
veux combien pour cela combien tu veux
2000 où 4000 signes qui minent 10010
milan l'équipage
français d'argent et les pierres sont à
moi pas d'états d'âme pour ce
diamantaire quant à naomi campbell
elle affirme qu'elle n'a pas conservé
ses diamants et qu'elle les a donnés à
une organisation humanitaire les récolte
russe ravagées par la canicule et la
sécheresse le premier ministre vladimir
poutine annonce ce soir un embargo sur
les exportations de blé jusqu'à la fin
de l'année
la russie troisième exportateur mondial
de céréales craint l'effondrement des
récoltes la pénurie et la flambée des
prix est pour l'instant ce sont les
forêts qui flambent les incendies
s'étendent désormais sur près de 200
mille hectares dans la partie
occidentale est la partie centrale du
pays
les feux de forêt continuent de
progresser de nouveaux foyers
apparaissent chaque jour vont ils tenir
leurs promesses de dons sous l'impulsion
de deux des plus grosses fortunes du
monde 40 milliardaires américains se
sont engagés à verser la moitié de leur
fortune à des organisations caritatives
sur la liste des philanthropes des noms
prestigieux et parfois inattendues chez
loïc de la mornais et nos correspondants
à washington
et si le côté obscur de la force était
bénéfique pour l'humanité et que dark
vador allaitent aider les nécessiteux
ce n'est pourtant pas une plaisanterie
la saga star wars a rapporté des
milliards à son créateur georges le
casse une grosse partie de ce trésor
intergalactique ira désormais aux
oeuvres de charité
le réalisateur fait partie des quarante
milliardaires américains qui viennent de
s'engager officiellement à donner la
moitié de leur fortune
il a rejoint l'appel de bill gates et
warren buffett respectivement deuxième
et troisième fortunes mondiales derrière
le mexique un élu qui ont lancé en mai
dernier la plus grande levée de fonds
privés de l'histoire nous étions
plusieurs milliardaires à table et j'ai
demandé à chacun d'entre eux de nous
dire quelle est l évolution de leur
philanthropie
comment il était arrivé là et qu'est ce
qu'il voulait accomplir dans la vie leur
calcul est simple à en donner le vertige
les 400 milliardaires américains
disposant au total d'une fortune de 1200
milliards de dollars c'est le pib d'un
pays milliardaire en habitants comme
l'inde
il demande à ce que la moitié de cette
somme serve pour le bien collectif
un projet qui repose sur la grande
tradition de charité aux états unis ici
les systèmes de protection sociale sont
bien plus faibles que dans d'autres pays
alors dans beaucoup de cas ce sont
finalement les personnes très riches qui
allaitent de fondations privées
compensent ces manques de l'état bill
gates et warren buffett ont donné
l'exemple en ayant déjà cédé la plus
grande partie de leur fortune à leur
fondation à travers elle bill gates a
par exemple fait vacciner 55 millions
d'enfants en afrique et en direct de
washington on retrouve notre
correspondant bonsoir maryse burgot
alors on imagine qu'après la crise les
affaires financières madoff notamment
c'est une annonce qui devrait séduire
l'opinion publique
oui marie c'est vrai que après la crise
financière
les milliardaires américains n'avait pas
la cote aux états unis on peut imaginer
que cette affaire va redorer leur image
mais cette histoire est initié par bill
gates illustre aussi une profonde
différence culturelle avec notre pays
ici la notion d'héritage est beaucoup
moins forte qu'en france
prenez par exemple
michael bloomberg le maire de new york
il est parti de rien il a fait fortune
mais il n'envisage pas systématiquement
de léguer sa fortune à ses enfants il
pense au contraire que c'est à leur tour
de maintenant repartir à zéro
voilà peut-être en partie l'explication
de cette philanthropie finalement très
anglo-saxonne merci maryse burgot en
direct de washington dramatique bavure
de l'otan en afghanistan les forces
internationales ont reconnu avoir tué au
moins douze civils lors d'une opération
menée avec l'armée afghane dans l'est du
pays
hier encore le général petraeus chef des
forces alliées en afghanistan exhortait
les soldats à faire le maximum pour
épargner les civils en afghanistan où
nos confrères de france 3 stéphane
taponier et hervé ghesquière sont
toujours retenus en otage avec leurs
trois accompagnateurs
nous ne les oublions pas cela fait
maintenant deux cent dix-neuf jours
pourriez vous mangez de la viande clonée
en grande bretagne deux bovins nés de
vache clonée ont été abattus et mise en
vente sans autorisation mais en
bénéficiant d'un vide juridique
les experts affirment qu'il n'y a aucun
danger connu pour la santé les
explications de laurence de chair et
patrick 10 me dans cette campagne
écossaise sont nés deux taureaux
descendant d'une vache clonée
l'éleveur a importé deux embryons des
états unis les taureaux au fini dans
l'assiette des britanniques
elle peut confirmer qu'en 2008 on a
importé des états unis des veaux d'une
vache clonée
il s'avère que c'est légal et que ça ne
pose aucun problème
un cas qui n'est pas isolé au total huit
embryons descendants de clones ont été
retrouvés alors un clown c'est quoi
plus besoin de taureaux il suffit de
prélever le noyau d'une cellule de la
vache et de l'introduire dans l'ovule
d'une vache porteuse
résultat une copie à l'identique les
consommateurs français sont ils prêts à
consommer du lait ou de la viande issus
de clones connais pas tous les risques
c'est pas quels sont les risques
associés a fait quelque chose mais qui
est en fait duplication de génétique
donc a priori chuch je suis content pour
attendre le point de vue des
scientifiques
si pour nous au niveau
santé santé on ne risque rien côté santé
les scientifiques français ont étudié la
question dans cette ferme de l'inra
vivent 40 claude evin descendants
officiellement les seuls sur le
territoire français ici la viande et le
lait sont détruits nos chercheurs
arrivent à la même conclusion que les
américains et les japonais cas d'eva qui
ont été nourris avec de la viande de
clone ou du lait et du fromage issus de
l'est de clown et on n'a pas constaté de
toxicité donc aucune différence avec des
animaux produits conventionnels mans
mais quel intérêt pour les éleveurs
trouver la perle rare qui produirait
beaucoup de lait et de viande et serait
toujours en pleine santé mais cloné une
vache aux états unis la technique coûte
encore 5000 $ elle l'a encore une fois
secteu mans aucun intérêt économique et
très peu montérégie n'était qu' à
d'autres méthodes beaucoup plus efficace
et qui n'ont aucune ambiguïté sur
lesquels nous travaillons en europe les
produits nouveaux doivent demander une
autorisation spéciale de mise sur le
marché mais il n'existe pas de
réglementation pour tout ce qui est
clonage
elle est prévue mais pour la fin de
l'année il est 20 heures 18 à suivre
dans votre journal pas de doute ce sont
bien des bleus mais pas les mêmes
laurent blanc a dévoilé la composition
de l'équipe
l'équipe de france qui affrontera la
norvège mercredi prochain
un célèbre desperados en passe de
rentrer officiellement dans l'histoire
de l'ouest près de cent trente ans après
sa mort billy the kid pour être
réhabilité
enfin lui est déjà entré dans l'histoire
celle d'hollywood
sylvester stallone très en forme vient
nous présenter le film de l'été des
expendables
il sera notre invité dans quelques
minutes comme mais d'abord ça roule pour
nicolas sarkozy en vacances depuis hier
au cap [ __ ] le chef de l'état a fait sa
première sortie à bicyclette ce matin
accompagné de son fils pierre et de
trois gardes du corps eux aussi à vélo
presque deux heures d'ascension sur la
route des crêtes avant de regagner la
résidence familiale de sa femme carla
bruni où il doit passer trois semaines
les bleus n'ont jamais si bien porté
leur nom ce sont les jeunes talents la
ligue 1 que laurent blanc a choisi
d'aligner pour le match contre la
norvège
11 août prochain entre suspensions des
inopérant du mondial retour des
disgracié et autre revenant le nouveau
sélectionneur de l'équipe de france
marque la rupture avec son prédécesseur
audrey riche et avec notre bureau à
lille dont les petits papiers du
sélectionneur le fruit d'une réflexion
pas si évidente une question de listes
en fait il y à la liste rouge celle des
23 grévistes sud africains privés de
match en norvège
et puis la liste d'attentes ses 22
joueurs convoqués aujourd'hui parmi eux
sept nouvelles têtes en sélection
debuchy trémoulinas ce matuidi des
petits nouveaux l'entousiasme aussi
mince que leur expérience sous le
maillot bleu c'est vrai que je vais pas
vous mentir je devais un petit espoir
grâce à s'est concrétisée aujourd'hui
c'est tant mieux je suis très content
très heureux c'est une fierté
dans cette fameuse liste s'ajoutent
aussi les oubliés de l'ère domenech
hatem ben arfa samir nasri et surtout
karim benzema malgré les ennuis
judiciaires du joueur et les
déclarations notamment de roselyne
bachelot et rama yade
laurent blanc est ce une son choix karim
comme d'autres peuvent faire partie
intégrante de noyau de l'équipe de
france dans le futur
ben ce qui concerne ce qui le touche
dans sa vie privée ne me regarde pas le
sélectionneur semble aussi avoir retenu
la leçon de l'affairé zahia
il se veut intransigeant sur le
comportement de ses hommes y la
discipline ne s'arrêtera pas au terrain
de l'équipe nationale je trouve un peu
anormal
même si j'ai pu - profiter qu'après les
matches les joueurs ces rapports un
petit peu d'un paris ou ailleurs il est
préférable que les joueurs soient
récupérées de suite après le match
pas question donc pour les petits
nouveaux de découvrir la vie nocturne à
oslo après le match amical surtout s'ils
veulent garder leur place en bleu malgré
le retour de certains mutins en
septembre
laurent blanc à qui et à nicolas anelka
rend hommage dans france-soir
aujourd'hui s'il avait été sélectionneur
des bleus au mondial nous n'en serions
pas là
s'attaquant s'explique sur cet échec
collectif et se défend d'avoir tenu des
propos rapportés par le quotidien
l'équipe
égratignant
violemment au passage raymond domenech
40 ans dit banni des bleus rentrés sans
un mot caché derrière ses lunettes
noires
nicolas anelka sort aujourd'hui de son
silence dans un entretien au quotidien
france soir l'attaquant français livre
sa vérité sur le mondial sud africain
c'était une vraie guerre celle des
joueurs contre la fédération et le coach
raymond domenech a réussi à me dégoûter
du football
anelka domenech c'est l'histoire d'un
psychodrame permanent avec comme point
d'orgue la mi-temps du match
france-mexique et les insultes présumées
de l'attaquant mise à la une de l'équipe
une fausse citation selon nicolas anelka
je marmonne dans mon coin des choses qui
resteront dans le secret du vestiaire et
qui auraient dû y rester
mais en aucun cas ce ne sont les mots
que j'ai pu lire dans l'équipe
aujourd'hui le joueur attaque le journal
en justice pour diffamation et un mois
et demi après le fiasco sud africain
anelka amer livre le fond de sa pensée
j'ai lu et entendu des propos racistes
sur nous quand ça se passe mal
alors on redevient des immigrés noirs ou
arabe racaille caïd banlieusard et
musulman
anelka retrouvera t-il un jour ses
anciens collègues de l'équipe de france
le nouveau patron des bleus laurent
blanc ne lui ferme pas la porte
l'enfant terrible du football français
n'a peut-être pas encore fini de faire
parler de lui
129 ans après le pardon peut-être le
gouverneur du nouveau mexique envisage
de réhabiliter billy the kid légendaire
hors la loi a battu à 21 ans par son ex
amie et shérif pat garrett de sa courte
vie on retient souvent sa cavale
meurtrière dans le far west à l'origine
de laquelle une promesse non tenue
maryse burgot florent des bois
le nouveau mexique à perte de vue les
paysages de la conquête de l'ouest où
s'affrontent airs cowboys et indiens les
terres aussi de billy the kid le plus
célèbre hors-la-loi de l'ouest qui a son
musée et ses supporters alors quand le
gouverneur de l'état parle de
réhabiliter la mémoire de billy ces
hommes-là applaudi je pense que c'était
plutôt un bon gars je ne dis pas qu'il
n'a tué personne mais souvent c'était de
la légitime défense mais lui n'est pas
d'accord il est le fier petit fils de
pat garrett
le shérif ce qui finit par abattre billy
the kid pour l'ubs il y était bel et
bien dans le camp des méchants hollywood
les médias tout le monde l'a décrit
comme un meurtrier est un voleur billy
the kid fut en 1880 l'homme le plus
recherché de l'ouest
au départ il n'est qu'un insouciant
voleurs de bétail un jour il accepte
même de se rendre mais le gouverneur de
l'époque ne tient pas sa promesse de le
gracier billy
commence alors une meurtrière cavale
malgré les assassinats qu'il commet
billy devient ce héros romantique
incarnée entre autres au cinéma par paul
newman
alors aujourd'hui dans les rues de santa
fe la capitale du nouveau-mexique
l'idée d'un pardon est largement
acceptée faute il ya si longtemps
pourrait lui pardonner qu'est ce que ça
change a place with no make
aujourd'hui les descendants du shérif
ont rendez-vous avec le gouverneur pour
empêcher cette réhabilitation posthume
dans sa tombe billy risque donc
d'attendre encore longtemps le pardon
promis jadis une vieille histoire de
parole non tenue dans ces plaines du
grand ouest
une arrivée digne d'une star de
hollywood et c'est normal c'est une star
de hollywood
à l'instar de john travolta de luc
besson sylvester stallone avait choisi
ce soir
rosny sous bois pour présenter son film
en avant première en france
tapis rouge au milieu des fans et il a
choisi france 2 pour venir parler de 10
expendables bonsoir sylvester stallone
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
sortie française de votre film le 18
août prochain ce film d'action que vous
réalisez dans lequel vous jouez
on vous retrouve avec mickey rourke
bruce willis dolph lundgren et également
arnold schwarzenegger je vous propose de
regarder ensemble la bande annonce et on
en parle juste rappelant que ce sont les
meilleurs mercenaires au monde
la seule vie qu'ils connaissent c'est la
guerre vous propose aux joies une
promenade de santé ou une virée en enfer
dans dix secondes vous allez voir ce qui
va sortir
c'est arrivé je suis fait exploser au
filet ce job à mon ami il adore
s'éclater dans la jungle pas vrai ouais
c'est quoi son problème
mais un souci
tu es malade tu as failli tout et
n'importe quoi même vous vous avez l'air
impressionné quand vous revoyez les
images n'ont surpris mais je ne me vois
pas c'est pas moi c'est pas si mal je me
dis en général j'ai une attitude très
critique
je regarde chez nous puis genre voit
comme ça c'était tout à fait une
aventure alors qu'ils sont dits experts
davos expliquez-nous comprennent que le
monde peut continuer à tourner sans eux
ce sont des mercenaires qui font la
guerre pour de l'enjeu qui n'ont pas de
famille qui n'ont rien que les uns les
autres ils sont un petit peu solitaire
mais il ya également la fraternité ils
se serrent les coudes alors l'action se
déroule en partie à vie les nac est une
île imaginaire
comment avez vous travaillé au brésil
notamment pour la réalisation de toutes
ces scènes d'action qui ont dû être
extrêmement compliqué effectivement
c'était très compliqué à les brésiliens
ont bien qu'au père nous a autorisés de
la pyrotechnique des explosions tout à
fait importante
nous avons vendu c'est la coopération il
ya une jungle authentique que c'est
notre disposition pour la deuxième
partie du film
nous on faisait la nouvelle orléans où
il ya eu l'ouragan il ya quelques oublis
à vue
des problèmes alors mickey rourke je
voudrais qu'on parle de lui un instant
et campe le personnage de toul qui
officiellement est devenu tatoueur mais
officieusement continuer à organiser des
missions clandestines
c'est un vieil ami à vous mais vous avez
une tendresse particulière pour lui ça
se voit parce que vous avez une manière
très particulière de le filmer je pense
notamment au premier tiers du film un
plan extrêmement serré où il parle assez
longuement
c'est émouvant pour vous de filmer mis
ko que je laime beaucoup ils fouillent
les père veilleux
c'est un personnage est un véritable
artiste j'ai dit mickey écoute pour
qu'il y ait la vérité qui sortent ce
film il faut que la caméra soit juste
sous son nez il faudra que tu parles
très sincèrement de ton coeur sinon le
film sur un échec et vous l'aurez une
possibilité fermement plus de temps donc
j'ai mis la caméra très très près de
lille il a parlé il a uni les gens
jusqu'aux larmes
c'est le message le plus important du
film voilà il y est arrivé
vous êtes un acteur mythique notamment
grâce à rocky et rambo pour présenter à
vous tous le cinéma d'action
on oublie aussi parfois vous avez
réalisé écrit et produit des films
mythiques aussi comme staying alive
vous avez même tourné dans des films
d'auteur vous avez même une apparition
dans bananas de de woody allen bref
acteurs auteurs réalisateurs et
producteurs quel est votre rêve
maintenant réalisé quelques films
supplémentaires quelque chose d'unique
et puis ensuite découvrir de nouveaux
talents les formes et trouver des jeunes
qui sont vraiment passionnés qui veulent
faire quelque chose de différent et
ensuite les aider parce que
j'y crois je pense qu'il faut agir avec
les tripes et j'aimerais bien trouver ce
genre de personne voilà ce que
j'aimerais faire à terme elle n'existe
pas encore à hollywood ces jeunes
personnes qui incarnent pour vous la
relève chez les hommes à hollywood les
jeunes acteurs leonardo assuré il ya
peut-être une quinzaine de personnes ils
ont presque
il faut quand même qu'on lance des défis
que ça marche il faut qu'on les pousse
un petit peu y aura un ou deux mais je
ne veux pas trouver des favoris parce
que je rentre chez moi et j'aurais
laissé tomber quelqu'un non un terme
quelqu'un de très fort sortira du lot ce
qui est arrivé avec arnold et bruce et
moi même les gens qui représente une
sorte de philosophie quelqu'un qui
représente quelque chose vraiment c'est
ça commence ils sont sur le point d'y
arriver
cette nomination sera très intéressant
merci beaucoup sylvester stallone thanks
for coming dit expendables sortie en
france le 18 août merci beaucoup
hall avant de refermer ce journal je
vous en rappelle l'une des principales
informations des tirs
la police a été visée hier soir à
villiers-le-bel et dans la nuit de mardi
à mercredi à auxerre ce sont des
incidents qui n'ont pas fait de blessé
et à grenoble aujourd'hui brice
hortefeux
ministre de l'intérieur a réitéré son
discours sécuritaire voulant faire de
grenoble dit il un symbole de la lutte
contre la délinquance tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec nathalie rihouet
pour la météo 20h35 enquête spéciale
présentée par paul nahon et bernard
benyamin demain à 13 heures vous avez
rendez vous avec sophie le saint et tout
le week end avec olivier galzi chpwn
soirée sur la deux
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr